WILL BE WATCHING.
>> Jason: FLORIDA AND GEORGIA
WATCH OUT.
I DON'T, THEY GIVE A MUCH PAIRED
WITH HURRICANE DORIAN BEARING
DOWN THE COAST OF FLORIDA,
PRESIDENT TRUMP CANCELED A PLANN
PRESIDENT TRUMP CANCELED A PLAND
PRESIDENT TRUMP CANCELED A PLANT
PRESIDENT TRUMP CANCELED A PLANO
PRESIDENT TRUMP CANCELED A PLANP
PRESIDENT TRUMP CANCELED A PLANL
PRESIDENT TRUMP CANCELED A PLANN
PRESIDENT TRUMP CANCELED A PLAND
PRESIDENT TRUMP CANCELED A PLANS
PRESIDENT TRUMP CANCELED A PLANO
HE CAN STAY IN THE
UNITED STATES TO MONITOR THE
STORM.
GOOD CALL MR. PRESIDENT.
SOME OF THE LEFT HOWEVER ARE
HOPING FOR A DESTRUCTION
INCLUDING FORMER CANADIAN
PRIME MINISTER KIM CAMPBELL WHO
TWEETED ABOUT THE STORM QUOTE
"I'M ROOTING FOR A DIRECT HIT ON
MAR-A-LAGO."
SHE LATER APOLOGIZED AND DELETED
THE TWEETS OF COURSE.
ADJOINING IS NOW IN THE REACTION
IS AUTHOR OF TAKEN FOR GRANTED,
FOX NEWS POLITICAL ANALYST YANA
CALDWELL AND TRUMP 2020 NATIONAL
PRESS
SECRETARY KAYLEIGH McENANY.
KAYLEE, WANT TO GO TO YOU FIRST.
ON THE SCALE OF DISGUSTING
DOESN'T GET GET ANY WORSE THAN
THIS?
>> I WOULD LIKE TO SAY NO IT
DOESN'T GET WORSE THAN THIS BUT
I THINK IT'S EQUALLY AS BAD WHAT
WE SEE COMING FROM THE LEFT
CONSISTENTLY.
IT'S NOT JUST THE PRIME MINISTER
ROOTING FOR DEVASTATION,
CATEGORY GET FOUR HURRICANE
HITTING FLORIDA LIGHTS AS YOU
RECALL YOU HAD JOHNNY DEPP
ROOTING FOR ASSASSINATION OF
THE PRESIDENT, KATHY GRIFFIN
HOLDING OUT THE PRESIDENTS HAD
COME I MEAN THESE PEOPLE ARE
SICK IN THE HEAD.
THIS PRIME MINISTER, THIS IS
DISGUSTING BUT IT COMES IN A
LONG LINE AND A LONG PATTERN OF
LEFTIST SAYING THINGS LIKE I
WANT TO BLOW UP THE WHITE HOUSE
WHICH IS WHAT ASHLEY JUDD
SAID SO IT'S A CONSISTENT
PATTERN HERE.
>> Jason: HER JUSTIFICATION, I
MEAN, SHE DIDN'T PULL IT DOWN
RIGHT AWAY BE A PART OF HER
JUSTIFICATION WAS THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS NOT DOING
ENOUGH OR CLIMATE CHANGE AND
WHEN HE CHANGE THE METHANE RULES
NOW SHE WANTS PEOPLE TO BE
KILLED AND DESTROYED AND
PROPERTY AND DESTRUCTION ON THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
ON THE SCALE OF DISGUSTING HOW
DO YOU RATE THIS?
>> BUBONIC PLAGUE.
I MEAN AT THIS POINT, WHEN
CONSIDERING WORLD LEADERS
CRITICIZE AND PRESENT ALL THE
TIME PUBLIC WE UNDERSTAND THAT
BUT IT'S INTERESTING TO SEE A
QUOTE ON QUOTE ALLY OF OUR
COUNTRY WISH DEATH ON AMERICANS
AND THIS HAS BECOME
EXTRAORDINARILY PROBLEMATIC
ESPECIALLY WITH CANADA AND I
THINK THIS IS INDICATIVE OF WHAT
WE SAW WITH USMCA.
THEY DON'T LIKE THAT WE HAVE A
PRESIDENT THAT HAS CREATED AN
AMERICAN FIRST POLICIES AND WHO
IS LOOKING OUT FOR OUR COUNTRY
FIRST AND FOREMOST.
AS YOU ALL KNOW, WE HAVE A TRADE
DEFICIT WITH CANADA AND THE
BILLIONS AND WE ARE CORRECTING
THAT RIGHT NOW AND WE HAVE A
PRESIDENT WHO IS NOT GOING TO
LAY DOWN SO I EXPECT MORE WORLD
LEADERS ARE GOING TO CRITICIZE
THIS PRESIDENT BUT HE IS GOING
TO CONTINUE TO WORK FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND CHOOSE US
FIRST BEFORE ANY OTHER COUNTRY.
>> Jason: 'S FORMER
PRIME MINISTER IS ONE OF THE
SHORTEST TERMS DISCREDITED.
SHE WAS ONE OF THE WORST
PRIME MINISTER AS THEY WERE HAD
PITTED OUT MANY AMERICANS EVEN
REMEMBER WHO SHE HAS BUT SHE IS
WORKING FOR JUSTIN TRUDEAU AND
SHE HAS THE JOB RIGHT NOW
THINKING WHO IS GOING TO BE THE
NEXT SUPREME COURT JUSTICE
THERE IN CANADA.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW THEY DO
THEIR LEGAL SYSTEM THERE BUT I
HEARD NOTHING FROM
JUSTIN TRUDEAU PAIRED WHAT'S
YOUR MESSAGE TO THE CURRENT
PRIME MINISTER?
>> THE CURRENT PRIME MINISTER
SHOULD CHASTISE HER AND ASK FOR
HER RESIGNATION.
AS JANELLE POINTS OUT, CANADA IS
OUR ALLY HERE.
TO HAVE SOMEONE SITTING IN THE
SEAT A GOVERNMENT AS YOU NOTED
ROOTING FOR THE DEATH OF PEOPLE
IN OUR COUNTRY IS UNACCEPTABLE
LANGUAGE FOR A LANGUAGE LIKE
THIS SHOULD HAVE CONSEQUENCES
AND STEPPING DOWN OR RESIGNATION
IS THE LEAST OF THOSE
CONSEQUENCES THAT SHE SHOULD
ENDURE.
WE HEARD PEOPLE ROOTING AGAINST
OUR ECONOMY BECAUSE THEY WANT
THE ECONOMY TO GO SOUTH TO SO
PEOPLE WOULD SUFFER SO THAT
DONALD TRUMP ISN'T REELECTED
AGAIN.
MR. CHO PASSED AWAY.
HE HAD PEOPLE CHEERING THAT ON
AS IF THAT WAS SOME SORT OF
EITHER JUSTIFICATION FOR THAT.
BUT HOW DO WE CALL THAT OUT?
HOW DO WE SAY ENOUGH IS ENOUGH,
CAN WE JUST ARGUE ABOUT THE
ACTUAL POLICIES AS OPPOSED TO
DEATH DESTRUCTION AND HARDSHIP
FOR OTHER PEOPLE?
>> WE ARE ACTUALLY DOING IT
RIGHT NOW ON OUR OWN FOX NEWS
AND I'M THANKFUL THAT I HAVE
COLLEAGUES THAT CONTINUE TO CALL
OUT THIS MESS ON A DAY-TO-DAY
BASIS AND INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH,
WHEN CONSIDERING THE FACT THAT
OUR ECONOMY IS THE BEST IN MY
LIFETIME AND WILL CONTINUE TO BE
THE BEST COMING OF MORE
AMERICANS WORKING THAN EVER
BEFORE COMING OF 7 MILLION JOBS
OPENING AND NOT ENOUGH PEOPLE TO
FILL THEM, THIS PRESIDENT HAS
DONE A TREMENDOUS JOB FOR OUR
ECONOMY.
HE'S GOING TO CONTINUE TO DO A
TREMENDOUS JOB AND HE'S GOING TO
CALL OUT THIS NONSENSE WHEN IT
APPEARS AND THAT'S ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I LIKE ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IT IS NOT GOING
TO SIT DOWN AND TAKE IT AS WE
HAVE SEEN WITH OTHER INDIVIDUALS
THAT HAVE LED IN THIS OFFICE AND
THAT INCLUDES REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS.
SO THIS IS A NEW TIME FOR US AND
WE ARE GOING TO GET YOU TO FIGHT
FOR IT BECAUSE WE ARE NOT TAKING
IT ANYMORE.
THE ONE CANADA IS OUR FRIEND,
IT'S OUR NEIGHBOR, WE LOVE THESE
PEOPLE AND YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'VE SEEN HURRICANES IN THE
PAST.
I REMEMBER WHEN HOUSTON HAPPEN,
IT WAS DEVASTATING BUT I SAW
AMERICANS COME TOGETHER.
IT DIDN'T MATTER RED, BLUE, WHAT
SIDE OF THE POLITICAL SPECTRUM.
THEY ALL CAME TOGETHER AND
THAT'S THE TYPE OF THING KNOWING
THAT THIS HURRICANE IS HITTING
AND DEVASTATING PEOPLE FOR US TO
THE BAHAMAS AND THAT IS COMING
TO THE UNITED STATES, WE PULLED
TOGETHER AS AN AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND THAT IS A POPULATION HERE IN
EARTH.